first of all the virtual evacuation
announcement eventual fire or other
emergency please exit the building all
tamanna the 70 point which is located
with our multi compo the fire exit in
this room is indicated by green fire
exit site please another lane evacuation
by collecting any belongings do not use
the lift the premises must not be
Richard reacted until alligators give
the all-clear placed and escape the Lord
spoke on these premises please note that
this making room we walk we are
recording this is point of increasing
wherever at video capture obviously
Boxford Monday morning and if I'm under
God's order
yeah okay I don't think why exactly -
maybe he got longer standing ok life all
had copies of the minutes of the last
meeting Ellen's version by 2017 so very
happy that I so I know this is an echo
heading to a group I can find receive
the declarations request it depends on
the Parish Council on will preferred
striving as challenge
yes the plaintiff doesn't like that
question are some simple things
remember centavos present yes I don't
know if I'm to declare one or more
capacity on here so I am a member of
writing Town Council yes just really
stated that it okay you should come up
to cause the lady please
owl at that time okay I'm going beyond
twice and six a refurbishment
construction of having convinced it in
the motion system not sure we must leave
London office all day
good evening off the brace vanish see a
report in front of today's with build on
city made for Council to that business
case whereby parish or town councils of
giving opportunity to take the
responsibility of running public
conveniences for ten year period in
short we are from for budget reflects
our capital which will be returned
investments are approximately at fifty
percent a payback of four years I'm
sorry
in summer you can use of low risk
projects and since secures a definitely
unhappy site questions on this okay
question Smith
okay Jen looking at written works is
converging on the core point while
malignant figures there and it's quite
contributing savings being a here
obviously there is a cap across to this
but as far as those same you concern are
they basically learning savings or
separation is really using so it's all
revenue so be perfect so as far as
that's concerned him and having that
under under our wing so SSB I think you
know the words speak for themselves as
far as portrait one is concerned I mean
the same is consumable it make a good
investment and the other thing I'll say
is it's taking a long time to get to
this I will acknowledge the work done by
both purposes and by a type of counsel
to experiment others are negotiating
this and you know it's a really good
deal when I think it'd be good for the
public going forward and modern really
big toilets for them to use you know
that's let's hope this is it started
things to come thank you
hey guys well yeah Thank You Sherman hum
increasingly cause just a few things I
missed lately like good showing here but
the we both works are so on page six
point to the above work some kind of a
complete because it will tend to possess
in exactly which which works we talked
about will be subjective significance so
those six points for now yeah refer to I
can speak when tomorrow yes very point
throwing over develop so that's the work
that some that will go out to tender so
if it's successful tonight it's a great
and emails and guns for council and what
would seek to do is to put those
veiled attendant okay just going on from
there to the you can see report
obviously be on 26:29 we've got the
estimates here of refurbishment yes
which one December that we've done by
self in Bubba Council penny we only got
one estimate really the third thing
it's absolutely it's what you'd expect
to do in this situation
so what we go out to tender will be
getting more than one crisis this more
following expected by the choir this one
number gets updated because to be
service sort of around the hills is
pretty high to be clear this is an
excellent it's based on their experience
of current proxies so the gentleman that
took this has a noticing three
refurbishment of public toilets in the
last year or so so because III haven't
heard those conversations and said these
are current prices and I had like the
concern that maybe sit right I said well
again a general building it could come
back with our quoted but that would not
be on the specification that we expected
to last ten years and it was quite clear
about that underst
I mean the tender process victim a
chairman will be the council spoken
process system for that I just wanted a
notice by the Town Council
he's hoping to find alternative
Committees of the building understand
for if you know this doesn't quite jell
with me that
it's refer service because oh really so
prior to trial Hill I'm just wondering
how all of that commercial useful move
on the asset team RVC have looked into
this property they feel that it is
gutted and made into a shell there is a
reasonable price for a rental facility
there is sufficient space next to the
present block for what we consider will
be the new toilets but I think the
conservative figure that he a very
conservative estimate is to gut and make
it should we say tactful would be in the
reason of 20,000 pounds the asset team
has indicated a very conservative 7,000
pounds a year rent is achievable it's
not necessarily going to be by somebody
who needs a shopfront
it could be a small business ie estate
agent chartered accountant somebody that
wants to have a high street location but
with not necessarily sometimes artistic
I'm just constantly with drift on to do
something hasn't been flexible every
night as you as you correctly lewd into
that Phyllis paper yes but in many ways
I find a contingency of well is that
does not go ahead I have either
if you complete everything is there
there is a cost sort of sort of
demolition of that building I'm not
saying that what we should do but it is
pretty consistent with the original
report the way to fall council where
that's that was sort of set out at the
time that we may well demonstrate
existing building to put new toilets
there so when we consistent with the
reports that we would prefer beforehand
I think invest involve that will be a
subset from separate papers and decibel
answer that later date around building a
certain one last question and giving
study that's understandable for page six
point nine is lovely refers the person
we service across the back thing lots
but and then the next page will be went
ten further figures for
battling lobster housing housing a
that's rough
well one is for being sort of expecting
these stickers here are for the proposal
that rocks and parish councils are
thankful and so are the figures of six
point nine in Table three or four the
added so if you're wishing to maintain
those toilets and they are now this is
the refurbishing cost or and we were not
taking this forward to the patch but we
were continuing to if you like service
the toilets FA are and we're running so
so the three kiloton so that lots for
parish want to do more than where we
first but Bronson parents I have a idea
of what they want yes your lab we're
done with fewer cubicles worked on them
we doing it thank you think that's
better
guess who's amazing Thank You mr. Chen
I'm just looking at the cleaning to
cross the river a contractor cleaning
for six toilet is there any impact on
the remaining three the rest of the
contract if we wanted to percent
reduction would it make any difference
in the price on drip is space-saving
being and this is probably why the paper
would set up a full council the time
zone that we would seek to close toilets
society weather across the districts so
to really recognize the signing with
with Cecil we would have to terminate
that seventh of the contract totally
like like possibly means I could try to
renegotiate if I wish but the issue will
be their staffing levels been expressed
no interest in doing so since ago you is
it well nothing for us so in so many
ways it will be better to certainly that
contract employees wanted to realize
exciting the other toilets at that point
thing will not be claimed but the looks
we shot anyway so if I understand you
correctly what you're saying is we're
going to terminate with a cleaning
contract three of three of the qualities
will be refurbished at the parish
councils table
yes and the refurbishment won't be able
repairable the maintenance Olivia the
other three will be closed occasional
maintaining there's only two others well
we've allowed for a budget for Hollywood
separately so you're trying because you
have a contract crisis nil I think
subject to consider yes subject OH - it
looks up to this type of the latitude
news is with that many publications here
I have a better more efficient have you
found Kings receive some things for life
as a golf costing for these
or rebuilding either and the lesser
deities needs probably a good guiding is
not because when you go out to same
process there could be a variation at
sorts in centage terms what are lots of
variation art could you expect really an
announcement at the head recommend 10%
contingency but I mean in many ways are
not many exactly it's not really we went
through that if you like scenarios so
again I understand though that expressed
over with the costumes that I think you
can example not that saying sometimes if
you reduced the cost of existing toilets
we've refurbished and so it's like
comparison comparing to Gaussian so if
you really reduce those same by 50% get
your 12 and costs because it's unlikely
and found them I spoke to again today
and something you know as well if it's
hardly you would still with a 10% return
on and vessel 50 today and he's still a
good invention to the concerns in many
ways you are looking at a business case
that that has some tolerance in in in
that sense so there wasn't some concern
for us for outsiders is it's still a
very good deal big deal but I'm
confident the prices in anything yeah
how many empty shops are Moravian
moments all right partly we know that's
it okay no I'm gonna be making our
building fixed let em say what they feel
more interested in Wrentham standing on
the high street rounds and rounds owner
to be clear again in the report hadn't
go into that detail and I've allowed for
a contingency that should that not
happen the costs are within these costs
so if we are fortunate and I believe
that you know that's - amen
management through the booklet we got to
do this and we're going to find a
positive use for that can heal toilets
existing ones
then the cost that we're proposing lets
you come back will come down within this
report even though those being am i
believe i've allowed for seventeen
thousand pounds a definition of
upgrading toilets and that that wasn't
again a quote from a local company good
son
so there is their contingency building
printers all right I think it's more
likely to be mixed by somebody not in a
small office then suddenly wanting a
retail shop type uni yes ok peasant
slave Thank You general and I just like
to say the outset that I am always going
to be in favor of new and improved
toilets but I'm sorry as I said before
council I'm not in favor of a different
president agrees clear because putting
the past essentially on to the parishes
and the town doesn't generate settling
the whole amount for the public first
sorry if we can see here the council
ignoring public person I know the rock
doesn't and I don't see why we should so
I find a metal object to that I think is
quite wrong to claim any little things
that in fact it shouldn't be conference
between or they're currently paying and
why ends up being paid out and Lansing
yield to the common person and I'm sure
you're either really hard job getting
that intelligent budget uniform through
to the public you understand finance and
there's a lot of them out there believe
me I've got a question and the question
relates to the leader brings whatever
form it takes if they're going to be a
break clause in favor of the town
council comparison stance of it for any
reason legal or otherwise they are
unable to perform
continue to perform the up
cleaning and maintenance of all the
toilets that they have the right to come
back to the District Council where the
District Council is obliged to consider
taking them back being the public policy
relates to the history Council if we
don't do that and something really awful
happens and it could happen parishes
could click out in fact there is a
proposition apparently or was before the
general election in family CLD so it
could be our friends in a place of tact
and on their own circumstances but my
very difficult to carry on other
responsibilities that they have and I
think it would be appropriate for the
district council include such a break
rules that I have seen you're not on our
last question the very Claudia pointed
forward to put in flop whether there
will be a clause that I happens if it's
not managed satisfactory that we could
we could sell now to that point there's
also things you might not liquid great
is inspecting the officer are very
clauses where we apparently put the town
council subject to the agreement would
be able to return to mystery council to
discuss preserving the service for them
in the event that you know something
really dreadful has happened to their
finances which could be determined by
when I don't testify yeah I think I
think we're drifting into the world of
completely unknown here councillor Mason
we have been very open and honest with
both the town and parish councils and in
fact it was their initiative that they
wanted to ten-year agreements they
didn't want the short term they were the
ones that proposed a ten year it came
unofficially initially and because of
where we have been to various meetings
with town and parish councils where
they've always expressed and involve or
once get involved in more management or
facilities within their towns or
parishes when this was proposed
previously there was no no interest
when the first things that came both
DeMarcus and myself and we've been out
to Paris
we are not taking these opportunity
three years we want a long-term
commitment and that with it and they are
aware that they're not naive the
accountant parish council they are very
aware of potential cabins they are also
very aware of other revenue streams they
may be able to bring in should captain
come into play so I'd like to reply to
that I don't say I listen to that but
I'll be awfully pleased if this appears
in the minutes because it may be the
parishes when you're aware of the use
that I have they may wish to prevent
rules I'm gonna get into nity there is
in public in recording and in the
minutes to have that available to the
Paris is to to read and understand
Thank You Mia relations television thank
you
Ranieri common decision and the
recommendation of expands does not make
it clear that the result of this
recommendation
hopefully by 2020 because and I think
reading the recommendation at it is is
this neighbor that that character right
mm scientist hot Audrey and I waked up a
lot part is discussion remember men is
part of these are that means giving
darling is hot as far as this particular
offenses desires not evening because
again that's a separate II know
welcome here just a clarification in
that is quite the recommendation and
Investment Board is not actually part
process about them and to in any way
shape or form to you we're too close for
the public toilets which are not our
initial cost me no type of this document
if you can read right away from You mr.
chairman
it's all very strange in the contract
the contract is going out that they now
became the ungrateful when it comes back
and you're inside be stage I mean if
additions you know making simplicity of
embedding boards about the case and
behind a member of various little
enclosure provinces I'm not looking to
go into this but we're we're fairly
optimistic non-local clothes on usually
the Hockley and an acquaintance one is
that they're both still under discussion
that both Paris cancer this stage that
would be wrong to something and you vote
because it's subject to discussions at
those particular variants so this stage
will have to leave okay any other
questions using recommendation gentleman
thank you recommendation these are
places on three just only the 6.4
presently committee amendments to full
council transfer o'reilly
roger public toilets we security have
attained release the rest the respective
parish town councils and that authority
be delegated assistant director of
environment consultation with a
portfolio of urban environment to
undertake installation refurbishment or
refrigerant replacements public
conveyances to allocating capital budget
of 3052 330,000 as set out in the report
funded by the transformational reserve
can I have a word in favor please
okay
boh-chan minutes challenges and five big
one it into solid time it's an eighty
three four five sitting porcelain do
something so the council amazing
recorded their personally I like this
okay moving on so I agree my state wait
right what you want to say anything on
this point gets can be him don't make up
reverse appropriate is a problem here I
think it's reasonably straightforward I
mean it's you know it it it's an it's an
arrangement that we put in place to
ensure that we can keep things operating
effectively aside the Vindhya between
is is concerned so the report is nothing
so thank you
and while we raise a witness of this 1x
replacement ISM and the attention would
be gem to revisit this when they set the
new city to director is is enforced and
elevations good when it and right okay
recommend action in expose that the
community resolves which one structure
we perform the point of this directive
green gateway trading limited the
effective on the club's device 2000 team
on an interim basis every other than on
simply hell that I pay isotope and
instead you get to once pointed and you
pose the place without a new threat to
blink a wagon train anyone as a Palin
sweetie thank you okay thank you very
much for you thanks again doctor has
just meet you
another reason slope on the line only
known about this does it is okay makes
it so 19
you